Hollywood is gearing up for the 75th
annual Golden Globe Awards tomorrow
night in Beverly Hills the event usually
known as one of the industry's biggest
parties is adopting a more serious tone
after explosive revelations about sexual
harassment and assault rocked the
entertainment world media vol has the
story
host Seth Meyers helped roll out the red
carpet it's part of preparations for the
first major awards show forced to
confront an industry-wide sexual assault
scandal do you want to talk about
obviously the elephant in the room while
also remembering that this year is about
the movies and television shows that
were made and now we realized they were
made under a lot worse circumstances
than we even understood one of the most
notable differences will be on the red
carpet where stars including Allison
Janney and Saoirse Ronan will be dressed
in black to show their support for
victims of sexual harassment and assault
it's part of a larger movement called
times up an initiative to advocate for
gender equality it includes a Legal
Defense Fund of 15 million dollars to
protect women in all industries I
particularly love that initiative
because it deals with people who are not
in front of the camera who are not
high-profile workers in this country who
totally feel under underrepresented and
this kind of empowerment I think is I
think it's crucial this is an
unprecedented initiative Matt Bellamy
editorial director of The Hollywood
Reporter says some stars are doing more
than just changing their outfits stars
themselves often will accept money to
wear certain dresses or suits and what
we've seen so far is that a lot of
people are pledging to donate that money
to the times up movement that's a way of
still dressing the part on the red
carpet and going through the motions but
helping a cause that the industry really
cares about right now a cause actresses
hope to talk about on the red carpet I
know from interviewers who are getting
ready for the red carpet that there's a
little bit of nervousness about how to
approach the issue
it's supposed to be glamour and fun but
now this is a serious issue that the
industry
confronting do you think this will also
translate to the stage as people are
getting their awards I think this issue
of sexual harassment is going to
dominate the actual show I think this
adds an element of intrigue and interest
to what can be a predictable award show
for CBS this morning Saturday midday of
Yael Hollywood I love a good red-carpet
interview this year it's gonna be even
better yeah it's gonna be a very
interesting the atmosphere is gonna be
very interesting